[MUSIC PLAYING]
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
So we've got a really
interesting panel session
today.
It's about what are the biggest
obstacles to agency success.
And essentially,
what I want to do
is take a slightly different
approach, because in this room,
we have people who
traditionally regard
each other as competitors.
You're all chasing after
customers together.
And actually, I want people
to take a step back from that
and think a little
bit differently.
So what if the
people in this room
could be your
collaborators as well?
They could actually help solve
the issues and the challenges
that you've got.
With that, we have an
absolutely brilliant panel here,
with a ton of great
experience, representing
a range of geographies.
So we have the US, India,
and the UK covered here.
I'm actually going to take
a rather lazy approach
to this panel and
get our panelists
to introduce themselves.
So with that, let's
start off with Jeff.
If you could introduce
yourself, and if you could also
give a one-line description
of your agency and what makes
it a little bit different.
JEFF NAMNUM: My
name is Jeff Namnum.
I am a partner at Touchlab.
We're based out of New York,
do work all over the states.
We are and the way we
describe ourselves is we
are America's Android-first
dev and design shop.
We're the ones that do the
crazy shit with Android.
PRADEEP NALLURI: Hey, guys.
I'm Pradeep here.
I'm representing Mutual Mobile.
I am partner at Mutual Mobile.
Mutual Mobile also is
full-scale services.
We do consulting, design,
engineering services
to Fortune 500 companies.
Our USP is that we focus
on few niche verticals.
And we are world-class at that.
We work with Fortune
500 companies.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
RYAN BATEMAN: My name's Ryan.
I'm a technical product
owner for Novoda.
Novoda's been writing
software and working in mobile
for about seven years now.
And we like to bill
ourselves as the world's
most ambitious mobile
product development agency.
So feel free to talk to
me about that, please.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
It's interesting.
Straight away, we can see
where differentiation comes
with each of those one-liners.
And I'm sure
everybody in the room
has got their own
answer to that,
their own source of
differentiation that
comes with it.
I'd like to come back
to one of the questions
we touched on very briefly
at the beginning, which
is about convincing customers.
So what's your biggest
obstacles you've
had in getting a customer
to adopt a new technology
or feature that you're
convinced is going to be really
good to them or for them?
And how have you actually gone
about solving that problem
and convincing them?
And Pradeep, maybe you
can answer this one first.
PRADEEP NALLURI: Yup.
Every client is different.
Some clients have a
lot of understanding,
because they have
a good tech team.
So their team come with-- they
actually choose a product,
and they come to us.
And sometimes we have to
push back, telling them,
that is not the right
product for your app.
Sometimes clients are-- we
work with the old economy.
They don't know anything.
They trust us blindly.
And those are the best
clients to work with,
because they believe in us.
[LAUGHTER]
So they leave the complete
the implementation to us.
So that's easy.
Actually, working
with a client who
know and they bring their
own director of product
or somebody, sometimes we
had to jump through hoops
to convince them.
We have to actually
do tech specs,
design specs to show them
that this is the best
way to actually approach it.
Just don't take the
engineering approach
or the design approach.
Look at the entire
[? integrated ?]--
from how is [INAUDIBLE]
help you achieve your ROI?
Maybe it's the best
product, but we
have to be
product-agnostic when we
are coming with the solution.
So that way, we
face difficulties,
but part of the game.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: So same
question to you. [LAUGHS]
RYAN BATEMAN: Yeah.
I think it is, as
Pradeep sort of mention,
I think it's about
establishing trust.
I think this is a common thing.
We're brought in as a source of
technical knowledge, a source
of technical expertise
either from the old economy
or from customers who
just trust us blindly.
And you can use
that as a currency.
I mean, trust is something
that can be exchanged.
You can say, you know,
I believe this product
or this technology
would really help you.
We're going to
spend a little bit
of this trust we built
through technical expertise
that we've demonstrated.
And we'll take your
timing down the road,
and we'll use some kind
of KPI for measuring what
the return on investment is.
But trust us this tiny distance.
Yeah.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
Anything to add?
JEFF NAMNUM: Well, these
guys really covered it well.
Right?
Trust is a huge thing.
I think our approach
is a solution, trust,
and a bit of obnoxiousness.
We focus very heavily on what
the solution is the client
is trying to accomplish.
And we build ourselves in such
a way that, where necessary,
we are obnoxious in refusal
to the point of sending people
away.
We recently had the opportunity
to build a corollary
to a big Apple project
and sent that client away
multiple times, because
they refused to approach
the project in the correct way.
It's a gutsy
direction sometimes,
and sometimes it's a
terrifying direction
when you're a small shop.
But it's been well
worth it to us.
We believe you're
just as defined
by the things you say no to
as the ones you say yes to.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
It's interesting seeing
the role of trust
to build that
credibility and allow
you to build the reputation and
the quality of products that's
so important there.
JEFF NAMNUM: Yeah.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: So the
next question I've got
is about how you actually
measure the customer
return on investment,
because you know,
there's an increasing
appetite for
data-driven decision-making.
And that's sometimes
quite challenging
to do within an agency
context when there
are a lot of unknowns around.
So how have you
approached the problem
of data-driven decision-making?
RYAN BATEMAN: Yeah.
I mean, the solution
to this is always
some kind of API-- sorry, KPI.
So pick a goal.
And everyone loves
kind of numbers,
graphs going up to the right.
Aim towards that.
And yeah, shoot for it.
I think as we've grown
as an agency as well,
we've bridged that gap between
just picking a dashboard
and hoping it goes
up, and trying
to understand the
business needs and where
that meets with the mobile
product kind of end result.
And I think at that point, you
can take a step back and say,
what is the broader
spectrum, what's
the broader context for
this mobile product we're
developing?
And do we need just
a KPI, or can we
actually understand what's the
impact of the greater business?
If there's a number or a graph
behind it, that's fantastic.
But all too often, as you say,
it's a bit more of a jump.
JEFF NAMNUM: Ryan
hit on the nose.
It is understanding the
business or the organization,
and whatever their goals are.
Once you know what
their goals are,
you can set a KPI, which
is the easiest way,
and it's the way the clients
think that they love.
Or you can help them understand
their goal better than they do.
They generally don't.
They think that they know
where they're trying to get to.
But once they take the time,
and trust you, and describe
their business to you and what
they're trying to accomplish,
if you can help
them set the goal
and help them understand that
they had misread what they were
actually trying to accomplish,
sometimes the KPI's
much less necessary.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
In terms of KPIs
that you see coming
up time and time again
that customers are
asking for, are there any
that spring to mind
as being things
that you see as recurring
requests or recurring things
that you need to
track and demonstrate?
PRADEEP NALLURI: They
usually are active users--
how many monthly active
users, engagement.
Every customer is different.
Some of them are coming--
they want an app to have
an e-commerce model on it.
They want to sell.
So they want to make sure
that customers are engaged,
they're coming back
to the app to buy.
So the design decisions
which go into their app
are completely different.
Then we have content creators,
magazines like "Economist,"
whom we've worked with.
They publish their
magazine once a week.
So they see a spike in
going up, but they also
actually want to monetize
their digital product, which
is struggling.
So we actually
helped them increase
their digital
monetization by 80% using,
actually, Google Play, actually.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
PRADEEP NALLURI: By 80%
in the last quarter.
They were not doing
that, and they were not
able to buy digital subscribers.
And we actually used Google
Play to integrate with them
and increase their revenue
by 80% in a quarter.
So not only-- we just
don't do the KPIs.
We also actually
help the customers
to realize new revenue
models, actually.
We had a customer called
Escort a couple of years back.
They were selling
these phone radars.
And it will tell Jeff
or Ryan that there's
a police radar right up front
of you-- like, slow down.
What we have
figured out is there
is a business model around it.
If we can capture the data,
put it on our private cloud,
and sell it as a subscription
to all the Escort owners,
they'll pay for it.
This is much before Waze.
This was four years before Waze.
So we actually helped customers.
Now we are working
with Varidesk.
I know people use
here Varidesk, right?
It's just a standing
desk, but we are actually
helping them open up
new revenue streams.
We are building a
connector office.
It's not just you
and your desk, how
do you work with your
colleagues who are around you.
Maybe you don't want
to be disturbed,
so you use a small-- we
are putting a small device
on the desk which will
tell people around,
like, don't disturb me.
So we are helping them build
a connected office space.
And we help them to--
we hope that they'll
realize new revenue from that.
JEFF NAMNUM: That's awesome.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
Yeah, excellent.
PRADEEP NALLURI: And
with Under Armour, we
actually helped them
realize $1 billion
in sales per annum using B2C.
We did their entire
Under Armour apps.
So we launched the
HealthBox in CES 2016.
We were the guys
behind the software.
So.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Excellent.
So how do you make that
move from, well, body shop,
essentially, to strategic
advisor, where, actually, it
means you have an insight
into what's really driving
the business rather than just
being, I would love to do it,
but my customer says they won't
pay for it or I can't, so where
you can build that level
of trust that allows you
to have that relationship
of influence that
makes the difference?
JEFF NAMNUM: At
the very beginning,
if you're not there-- and we
were not there three years ago.
It's changing your own mindset.
When you have been a body
shop-- that's a good term.
When you've been a
body shop for so long,
you get used to
being a body shop.
You diagnose the
problems with the car.
And you say you have a ding
here and you have a ding here,
let's take them out, let's buff
'em, and let's polish this,
and let's paint it.
You have to internally
either change the mindset
or hire the capacity.
And until you do, that's
a tough leap to make.
But once you do, then it's
a matter of boldly going,
I think.
You got to put yourself in front
of that client and say, look,
we have looked at
your numbers, we
have looked at
what you're doing,
I understand that you
want to build this app.
But if you're trying
to affect this,
then this is the thing that you
really should be working on.
And we would love to
help you get that done.
And these are the reasons
why, and these are the numbers
that we see.
And it's making that transition.
It's as much a mindset
and an internal thing
as it is a branding situation.
RYAN BATEMAN: Yeah, I would
say as well as Jeff said,
it's a case of getting a little
bit obnoxious occasionally
and saying, hm, we
have this demonstrated
technical expertise and
experience over the years.
Trust us to help you
form your strategy.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
Excellent.
Do you think there's
a greater role
that Google should
or could be playing
in terms of educating customers
to do the right thing?
I mean, we try and
produce the documentation,
we try and talk to people
at conferences, and events,
and partners, and so on.
Is there a trick that
we're missing here?
Is there stuff we should
be giving you, as agencies,
to make you more successful?
Anything spring to mind?
PRADEEP NALLURI: Yeah, I
think you can help us a lot.
The big brands
know you very well.
I think you are engaging with
the big brands-- the Nikes,
ESPN.
I think you have a
contact with all of them.
But when we are working with
old economy or the smaller
companies, when we try
to take, for example,
a wearable-- last year when
the Google wearable came out,
when we tried to
ship products on it,
first thing they question us is
how many devices were shipped,
how many people bought Google
Watch, how many people actually
are using it, what
are the monetization.
Probably, you can help
reach out by publishing
these reports, which will
help us to sell with authority
your products which you have.
But we go and talk to Nike,
they know about you guys.
They know what you
are going to do,
because probably,
they have early access
or your guys are already
engaging with them.
And you have a single point
of contact talking to them.
So that helps.
But for the smaller
brands, which
is 80% of the market,
smaller shops, or smaller
companies, old economy
companies, they have no clue.
JEFF NAMNUM: Yeah.
Like hell yeah.
But in addition to that,
I would say, specifically
for older economy companies,
I won't go on my tirade
that the glass barely
matters, it just
matters because
it's in your pocket.
But I think one piece that we
are seeing increased demand
for daily now-- screens.
Screens on things.
In particular talking
about Android.
It is relatively ridiculous
that there are $1,000 iPads
on conference room walls.
Really?
You have to put it
in a special box
so that nobody touches
the little button,
where Android can be very
easily fitted to that situation.
I am surprised not to hear
more discussion around Android
for screens on things.
RYAN BATEMAN: Yeah.
I would class that almost as
what I would call the CEO's
phone problem, as in
the CEO has that phone,
he knows it, that's
the Glass he has.
It does the thing.
And so he wants that
on the conference wall.
So going back to
your question, I
would say something like
general mobile education
and return on
investment for something
like the old economies.
What's your avenue?
What can investing in an
Android and an iOS app,
what can that give
you as an end result
as somebody who's a newspaper
publisher or somebody who
doesn't know that world at all?
And the general
economy would help.
Sorry, that general education
would certainly help.
I think agencies in
general be able to say,
the next step is
we need to do this.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: That's
certainly something
we're going to try and work on.
And it's really
useful [INAUDIBLE].
PRADEEP NALLURI: If we can get
some firsthand reports from you
directly-- like how
the product's doing,
adaptation rate, all of
that, that will help.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
I mean, there's
always limits about what
we can share, but yes.
PRADEEP NALLURI: To
give you an example,
we were talking to a client
recently-- not recently,
six months back.
And they actually
choose us because we
said that we will go with
Swift rather than Objective C.
And how the heck do they know?
They're an old-economy company.
Entire media was
reporting about Swift--
it's the highest adapted
programming language ever
in the history of mankind.
All of that kind of
headlines were happening.
So I think with Google
products, they're really nice.
They're excellent.
But if you can get more media
coverage and more reporting,
that will help us a lot
when we go to the customers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]